hi my name is a Dahlia garduno I'm from
El Paso Texas and I'm currently a
student at Texas A&M University and
College Station and I just wanted to
first of all thank you very much for
your invention your technology has
changed and revolutionized education and
entertainment and I wanted to ask what
did you study in school what led you to
be interested in something this
revolutionary thank you ok so in school
I studied ok literature history
mathematics physics chemistry and then
at the University merrily chemistry
physics and mathematics so nothing
revolutionary and even during my PhD and
you in the beginning of my career
research of course I had the feeling
that I could obtain original results but
I had never the feeling that this was
revolutionary it's only recently that
when I begin for the final results after
many years of research that Typhon he
was not so bad and revolutionary I don't
know but certainly I can see that market
leaders that to some to a new field of
research risk all spintronics and also
to some application that many body many
people use in many countries today